القوات المسلحه هي واحده من الاعمده
الرئيسيه لاي دوله حول العالم لذلك يجب ان
تكون دائما محترفه جزء من احترافييتها
يكمن في ابتعادها عن اي عمل سياسي او
انتماء طائفي
منذ ان نقضي الخميني على السلطه في ايران
في عام
1979 تغيرت المعادله في ايران وفي عدد من
الدول المجاوره له بمرور السنوات بدانا
نرمي للشيعه عقائديه وحزبيه هذه
الميليشيات اما تدين بالولاء لكيانات او
لطوائف او حتى لافراد دون ادنى اعتبار
لسياده الدوله او لمصالحها حول انعكاس
وجود مثل هذه الميليشيات على الدول بشكل
عام وكذلك على المؤسسات العسكريه بشكل خاص
معنا دكتور مايكل نايتس المتخصص في الشؤون
العسكريه والامنيه لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط
دكتور مايكل اولا اهلا بك معنا في عسكريا
نجحت ايران في تشكيل اشياء عقائديه لظروف
مرتبطه بالثوره عام 79 لكن برايك كيف نجح
الطهران في تصدير هذه الفكره لدول مجاوره
سواء في العراق او في اليمن او في سوريا
او في لبنان او في اليمن
الرونج
الثوري الايراني حدود ايران عبر تطوير جيش
عابر للحدود
حيث ركز الاخير فقط على تصدير الثوره
وانشاء قوات صغيره تحاكي الحرس الثوري في
كل مكان عبر ارجاء الشرق الاوسط وذلك ما
فعله حقا حدث ذلك في هذه الامر في لبنان
ومن ثم في سوريا واليمن والعراق عاداك عن
اماكن اخرى
الدكتور مايكل برايك كيف يؤثر وجود مثل
هذه الميليشيات على القرار السيادي للدوله
وكذلك كيف تتعامل الدول التي لديها مؤسسات
امنيه اضعف من هذه الميل الشياط
القدس في اضعاف نفوذ القوات العسكريه
نظاميه في لبنان واليمن والعراق وسوريا
ويريدون فرضا هيمنه فيلق القدس على
الميليشيات بحيث تغدو لها السلطه العسكريه
العليا في هذه الدول وهذا ما حدا
بالايرانيين لنشر منشور في عام 2014
يتباهون فيه بفرض سيطرتهم على اربع عواصم
عربيه هي بيروت ودمشق صنعاء وبغداد يريدون
للمليشيات ان تتسلم رويدا رويدا زمام
الامور ليس في المجال العسكري في حسب
وانما كذلك في المجال الاقتصادي حيث
يمكننا في العراق على سبيل المثال رؤيه
شركه هندسيه جديده تدعم هندسه وفي طور
الارشاء ومجموعه خاتم الانبياء التي يراد
لها ان تكون مركز خاصه بالحرس الثوري
للطاقه والبنت تحتيه في ايران وبالتالي
فهم يريدون فردهم على قطاع الاعمال كذلك
الدكتور مايكل بعد 2001 10 وما سمي
بالربيع العربي ظهرت عدد من الميليشيات
يعني لديها ارتباط سواء بمصالح اقتصاديه
او حتى ارتباطات سياسيه مع بعض قاده
الطوائف او شيء من هذا القبيل برايك
الحلول في مثل هذه الدول مثل ليبيا على
سبيل المثال الحل في هذه الدول يجب ان
يكون ما بين الميليشيات وبعضها البعض ام
انه ما بين القوه الخارجيه التي تؤثر في
تحرك هذه الميليشيات على الارض
يا رب ستورينج العربي
الدولي في عدد من البيئات منها اليمن
وليبيا وسوريا كذلك وفي ذلك النوع من
البيئات من السهل للقوه الخارجيه التدخل
في دول ذات السياده لذلك في ليبيا على
سبيل المثال لدينا الحكومه التي تتخذ من
طرابلس مع قرر لها والفصائل في بنغازي وكل
من الطرفين يلتمس رعاه خارجين مختلفين
والامر ذاته ينطبق على اليمن حيث نشاهد
بعض المليشيات التي تميل نحو المعسكر
الايراني وهم جماعه الحوثيين وفي المقابل
لدينا ميليشيه اخرى تتلمسوا مساعده
المجتمع الدولي في محاوله للحفاظ على وحده
الحكومه اليمنيه لذلك شرعت دول ضعيفه
ابوابها امام التدخل الخارجي فقط بهدف
الشد من عضد هذه الدول واستعاده قوه
المؤسسات الحكوميه ولا سيما قوه اجهزتها
العسكريه والاستخباراتيه في سبي احد من
قوه الميليشيات
الدكتور مايكل في اليمن هناك ميليشيات
الحوثي هذه الميليشيات تم تصنيفها كجماعه
ارهابيه ثم رفعت بعد ذلك مع وصول اداره
الرئيس جو بايدن الى السلطه من هذه
القوائم التعاطي السياسي مع مثل هذه
الميليشيات برايك هل هو امر صحيح وعلى
الجانب الاخر كيف يؤثر هذا الامر التعاطي
السياسي مع مثل هذه الميليشيات على الامن
الاقليمي والامن الدولي ايضا
وضي باودم من السعوديه
لازاله حركه الحوثي انصار الله من قائمه
المنظمات الارهابيه الاجنبيه لكنها ادرجت
قاده وافرادا من جماعه الحوثيين في تلك
القوائم فضلا عن شبكات تهريب الحوثي فهم
يقرون ارتباطات الحوثيين الارهابيه لكن ما
يريدونه هو عدم عرقله تقديم المساعده
الانسانيه التي تشمل الغذاء والوقود الى
الامانه عبر تسميه المنظمه برمتها على
انها ارهابيه لكن مع الوقت قد نشهد ادراج
اجنحه الاخرى داخل جماعه الحوثيين ك
ارهابيين لكننا من حيث الواقع نعامل معظم
افراد الحركه باعتبارها حركه ارهابيه وهذا
هو الاتجاه الذي لا يسير فيه لا شك ان
الناس سمعنيون في المقام الاول بضمان وقفي
لاطلاق النار في اليمن ورغم ان الوقفه
رسميه لاطلاق النار قدميه بالفشل الى ان
هناك وقفا غير رسمي لاطلاق النار لا يزال
صامدا بما في ذلك تص وقف الهجمات على
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وعدد من دول
الخليج الاخرى لذا ستستمر بعض المفاوضات
حيث ان جماعه الحوثيين الان بحاجه الى
المال لدفع رواتب الموظفين المدنيين
ولاسباب تتعلق بالفساد لذلك قد يحصلون على
بعض الاموال ويسمحون للحكومه بتصدير النفط
والغاز لذلك فاننا ما دون قدما في طريق
المفاوضات
في العراق دكتور مايكل هناك تجربه لدمج
ميليشيات عقائديه داخل المؤسسات الامنيه
الحشد الشعبي على سبيل المثال برايك هل
نجحت هذه التجربه وهل اثبتت هذه
الميليشيات انها قابله للانصهار في
المؤسسات الامنيه والعسكريه وانت تتخلى عن
خلفياتها الايديولوجيه بشكل اخر
تحشر الشعبي يعد الحشد الشعبي رسميا جزءا
من قوات الامن العراقيه وذلك هو مقامت به
حكومه حيدر العبادي و عادل عبد المهدي
فهما من حيث مبدا القاده المسؤولون عن
القوانين العسكريه في العراق وبصوره نظريه
حال الحشد حال اي جزء اخر من قوات الامن
ويتعين عليهم التصويت في يوم المحدد ليس
مع المواطنين العاديين اقصد انه من غير
المسموح ان يكون احزما سياسيه لكن الحشد
يخالف معظم القوانين التي يتعين على سائر
القوات العراقيه الامنيه الامتثال لها
وتكمل المشكله في ان هذا الوضع ملائم
للغايه بالنسبه لهما لانه في حال قتلهم
احدا ما في الشارع في يمكنهم اشهار بطاقته
تعريف الحشد الشعبي الخاصه
امام محكمه الحشد الشعبي اي المحكمه
العسكريه هو يعني ذلك انه بوسع اي شخص
الحصول على بطاقه تعريف الحشد الشعبي
وتملص من ايدي العداله لذلك يعد الحشد
الشعبي مثالا على فشل الاندماج حيث يحصلون
على ميزات مثل الرواتب والتقاعد والمنح
والحمايه من القانون المدني لكنهم لا
يرقون لامتثال لايه مسؤوليات ينص عليها
الانتماء للقوات الامنيه بما في ذلك قواعد
الانضباط وعدم الانخراط في السياسه